jetzt geht Scholz auf Lauterbach los in
Sachen Corona sind die zwei alles andere
als einer Meinung Scholz gegen
Lauterbach im corona-duell Zweier
Doktoren die Rede ist nämlich von ihm
hier er ist der Bruder von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz Professor Dr Jens Scholz
Chef des Uniklinikum Schleswig-Holsteins
und da wo sein Bruder immer gerne
schweigt und emotionslos wirkt haut er
jetzt ordentlich drauf und zwar auf die
corona-politik von Gesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach Österreich schafft die
corona-quarantäne ab Frankreich hebt
alle Regeln auf ja und das macht
Deutschland bei uns hält
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach an
Quarantäne und Tests fest ja das hält
Professor Dr Jent Scholz für falsch und
Bild hat exklusiv mit ihm gesprochen da
muss man ehrlich sagen diese
Abschottungspolitik ist in die Hose
gegangen so sein Zitat Professor Jens
Scholz Bruder des Bundeskanzler der hat
eben eine ganz klare Haltung und wir
wollen noch mehr über dieses exklusive
Interview hören deshalb ist jetzt
bildpolitikredakteur Sebastian Geißler
bei uns im Studio schönen guten Morgen
sebastian hat der Bruder von Olaf Scholz
da wirklich ein Nerv der Zeit getroffen
es dient schon sehr plausibel was er
sagt er beklagt sich eigentlich darüber
er ist ja schlleiter einer Klinik er
weiß wovon er spricht er ist auch im
Garten Mediziner er sagt ihm fahren
einfach zu viel zu viele Pflegekräfte
zum Beispiel aus weil die wenn sie
positiv getestet werden wenn sie
Symptome haben lange in Quarantäne gehen
müssen sich isolieren müssen selbst wenn
sich eigentlich schon wieder gesund sind
symptomfrei sind müssen die sich dann
irgendwann frei testen so will es Karl
Lauterbach er sagt also jetzt Scholz
sagt hier das ist eigentlich in der Form
Unsinn man sollte es lieber handhaben
wie bei der Grippe wenn man krank ist
auch als Pfleger natürlich kommt man
natürlich nicht krank zur Arbeit man
könnte sich auch einfach selbst testen
selbst schützen und einfach dann mit
einer Maske wieder zur Arbeit kommen zum
Beispiel das heißt das richtet hier
tatsächlich ein bisschen Schaden an was
Karl Lauterbach sagt und dass er so auf
von dem Mediziner Klinikchef contra
kriegt es schon bemerkenswert du sagst
es richtig Schaden an wird das also
Auswirkungen auf die Beziehung zwischen
Olaf Scholz und Karl Lauterbach haben
dass sich der Bruder jetzt öffentlich
geäußert hat das ist schon durchaus also
könnte man schon glauben dass einfach
Karl Lauterbach dann auch mal eine SMS
schickt an Olaf schaut und sagt Mensch
Olaf du musst mich du musst mich retten
jetzt hat dein Bruder mich hier so
reingerissen da musste was machen das
wird Olaf Scholz aber nicht tun der hat
mit seinen Brüdern auch eine Art
greement wir reden nicht öffentlich
übereinander und kann Lauterbach ist ja
auch intern ein bisschen angeschlagen es
kommt auch in den eigenen Reihen nicht
so gut an auch in seinem Ministerium
mich dass er immer wieder vor prescht
der warnt jetzt schon wieder auf einer
killervariante auf die bei uns
vorbereiten müssen das ist ein sehr
apokalyptischer Ton die Bereitschaft ihm
jetzt zur Hilfe zu kommen an dieser Lage
die ist auch im Bundeskabinett eher
eingeschränkt wie schätzt du die
corona-politik in den nächsten Monaten
ein du hast es schon gesagt er ist immer
noch in Alarmbereitschaft und das wird
er sicherlich auch bleiben oder Karl
Lauterbach ja das ist ein bisschen
Fehler dass wir in diesem
apokalyptischen Ton ist da ist ja auch
kritisiert worden dafür dann sagt er na
ja wir bereiten uns ja nur vor heißt ja
nicht dass so eine Killer Variante
tatsächlich kommt also kann Lauterbach
Täter eigentlich gut daran dem Beispiel
unserer Nachbarn zu folgen Frankreich
Österreich die diese Maßnahmen
abschaffen Vorbereitung ist immer gut
aber dieser apokalyptische Ton der ist
einfach eins drüber wir haben eigentlich
gelernt mit der Pandemie zu leben wir
haben gelernt mit dem Virus zu leben das
müsste eigentlich jetzt Modus sein und
nicht dieser dieser panikmodus der dafür
sorgt dass viele Menschen Karl
Lauterbach auch einfach nicht mehr ernst
nehmen und seine Warnung schönes
Schlusswort vielen Dank Sebastian
Geißler
[Musik]